الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
استووا استووا اعتدلوا سووا الصفوف وسدوا
الفرج الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم را كتاب احكمت اياته ثم فصلت من لدن
حكيم خبير الا تعبدوا الا الله انني لكم
منه نذير وبشير وان استغفروا ربكم ثم
توبوا اليه يرسل الس وان استغفروا ربكم ثم
توبوا اليه يمتعكم متاعا حسنا الى اجل
مسمى ويؤت كل ذي فضل فضله وان تولوا فاني
اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم
كبير الى الله مرجعكم وهو على كل شيء
قدير الا انهم يثنون صدورهم ليستخفوا منه
الا حين يستغشون ثيابهم يعلم ما يسرون وما
يعلنون انه عليم بذات
الصدور وما من دا
ابه في الارض الا على الله رزقها ويعلم
مستقرها
ومستودعها كل في كتاب
مبين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وهو الذي خلق السماوات والارض في سته
ايام وكان عرشه على
الماء ليبلوكم ايكم احسن
عملا ولئن قلت انكم مبعوثون من بعد الموت
ليقولن الذين كفروا ان هذا الا سحر
مبين ولئن اخرنا عنهم العذاب الى
ام الى امه محدوده ليقولن ما
يحبسه ولئن اخرنا عنهم العذاب الى امه
معدوده يقولن ما يحبسه الا حين ياتيهم الا
يوم ياتيهم ليس مصروفا عنهم وحاق بهم ما
كانوا به
يستهزئون ولئن اذقنا الانسان منا رحمه ثم
نزعناها منه انه ليوس
كفور ولئن اذقناه
نعماء بعد ضراء مسته ليقولن ذهب السيئات
عني انه لفرح
فخور الا الذين صبروا وعملوا
الصالحات اولئك لهم مغفره واجر كبير اولئك
لهم مغفره واجر
كبير فلعلك تارك بعض ما يوحى اليك وضائق
قم به صدرك ان
يقولوا ان يقولوا لولا انزل عليه كنز او
جاء معه ملك انما انت
نذير والله على كل شيء
وكيل الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏s
استو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعم انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ام يقولون
افتراه قل فاتوا بعشر سور مثله مفتريات
وادعوا من استطعتم من دون الله ان كنتم
صادقين فان لم يستجيبوا لكم فاعلموا انما
انزل بعلم الله وان لا اله الا هو فهل
انتم
مسلمون فان لم يستجيبوا لك لكم فاعلموا
انما انزل بعلم الله وان لا اله الا هو
فهل انتم مسلمون
من كان يريد الحياه الدنيا وزينتها نوفي
اليهم اعمالهم فيها وهم فيها لا
يبخسون اولئك الذين لم يكن لهم في الاخره
الا النار اولئك الذين ليس لهم في الاخره
الا النار وحبط ما صنعوا فيها وباطل ما
كانوا يعملون
افمن كان على بينه من ربه ويتلوه شاهد منه
ومن قبله كتاب موسى اماما ورحمه اولئك
يؤمنون به ومن يكفر به من الاحزاب فالنار
موعده فلا تك في مريه منه انه الحق من ربك
ولكن اكثر الناس لا يؤمنون
ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
اولئك يعرضون على ربهم ويقول
الاشهاد ويقول الاشهاد
هؤلاء الذين كذبوا على ربهم الا لعنه الله
على
الظالمين الذين يصدون عن سبيل الله
ويبغونها عوجا وهم بالاخره هم
كافرون اولئك لم يكونوا معجزين في الارض
وما كان لهم من دون الله من
اولياء يضاعف لهم
العذاب ما كانوا يستطيعون السمع وما كانوا
يبصرون
اولئك الذين خسروا انفسهم
يوم القيامه وضل اولئك الذين خسروا انفسهم
وضل عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون لا جرم انهم في الاخره هم الاخسرون
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات واخبتوا
الى ربهم اولئك اصحاب
الجنه اولئك اصحاب الجنه هم فيها خالدون
مثل الفريقين كالاعمى والاصم والبصير
والسميع هل يستويان مثلا افلا
تذكرون ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه اني لكم
نذير
مبين الا تعبدوا الا الله اني اخاف عليكم
عذاب يوم اليم
فقال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه ما نراك
الا بشرا مثلنا وما نراك اتبعك الا الذين
هم اراذلنا بادي الراي وما نرى لكم علينا
من فضل بل نظنكم
كاذبين قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على بينه
من ربي واتاني رحمه من عنده فعميت عليكم
انلزمكموها
وانتم لها
كارهون ويا قوم لا اسالكم عليه مالا ان
اجري الا على الله وما انا بطارد الذين
امنوا انهم ملاقوا ربهم
ولكني اراكم قوما
تجهلون و يا قوم من ينصرني من الله ان
طردتهم افلا
تذكرون ولا اقول لكم عندي خزائن الله ولا
اعلم الغيب ولا اقول اني ملك ولا اقول
للذين تزدري اعينكم لن يؤتيهم الله خيرا
الله اعلم بما في انفسهم اني اذا من
الظالمين قالوا يا نوح قد جادلتنا فاكثرت
جدالنا فاتنا بما تعدنا ان كنت من
الصادقين قال انما ياتيكم به الله ان شاء
وما انتم
بمعجزين ولا ينفعكم نصحي ان اردت ان انصح
لكم ان كان الله يريد ان
يغويكم هو ربكم واليه
ترجعون ام يقولون
افتراه قل ان افتريته فعلي اجرامي وانا
بريء مما
تجرمون الله اك
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
واوحي الى نوح انه لن يؤمن من قومك الا من
قد امن فلا تبتئس بما كانوا
يفعلون واصنع الفلك باعيننا ووحينا ولا
تخاطبني في الذين ظلموا
انهم
مغرقون ويصنع الفلك وكلما مر عليه ملا من
قومه سخروا منه قال ان تسخروا منا فانا
نسخر منكم كما
تسخرون فسوف تعلمون من ياتيه عذاب يخزيه
ويحل عليه عذاب
مقيم حتى اذا جاء امرنا وفارت النور قلنا
احمل فيها من كل زوجين اثنين واهلك الا من
سبق عليه القول ومن امن وما امن معه الا
قليل وقال اركبوا فيها بسم الله مجريها
ومرساها ان ربي لغفور رحيم وهي تجري بهم
في موج كالجبال
ونادى نوح ابنه وكان في معزل يا بني اركم
معنا ولا تكن مع
الكافرين قال ساوي الى جبل يعصمني من
الماء قال لا عاصم اليوم من امر الله الا
من رحم وحال بينهما الموج فكان من
المغرقين
وقيل يا ارض ابلعي
ماءك ويا سماء اقلعي وغيض الماء وقضي
الامر واستوت على الجودي وقيل
بعدا وقيل بعدا للقوم
الظالمين ونادى نوح ربه فقال رب ان ابني
من اهلي وان وعدك الحق وانت احكم
الحاكمين قال يا نوح انه ليس من اهلك انه
عمل غير صالح فلا تسالني ما ليس لك به علم
اني اعظك ان تكون من
الجاهلين قال رب اني اعوذ بك ان اسالك ما
ليس لي به علم والا تغفر لي وترحمني اكن
من
الخاسرين قيل يا نوح اهبط بسلام منا
وبركات عليك وعلى ام وعلى امم ممن
معك قيل يا نوح اهبط بسلام منا عليك وعلى
وبركات عليك وعلى امم ممن معك وامم
سنمتعهم ثم ي مسهم منا عذاب
اليم تلك من
انباء الغيب نوحيها
اليك ما كنت تعلمها انت ولا قومك من قبل
هذا فاصبر ان العاقبه
للمتقين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والى عاد اخاهم هودى قال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره ان انتم
الا
مفترون ويا قوم لا اسالكم عليه اجرا ان
اجري الا على الذي فطرني افلا
تعقلون يا قوم لا اسالكم عليه اجرا ان
اجري الا على الذي فطرني افلا تعقلون ويا
قوم استغفروا ربكم ثم توبوا
اليه ويا قوم استغفروا ربكم ثم توبوا اليه
يرسل السماء عليكم مدرارا ويزدكم قوه الى
قوتكم ولا تتولوا
مجرمين قالوا يا هود قد ج قالوا يا هود ما
جئتنا
ببينه وما نحن بتارك في الهتنا عن قولك
وما نحن لك
بمؤمنين ان نقول الا اعتراك بعض الهتنا
بسوء قال اني اشهد الله واشهدوا اني
بريء مما
تشركون من دونه فكيدوني جميعا ثم لا
تنظرون اني توكلت على الله ربي وربكم ما
من
دابه الا هو اخذ
بناصيتها ان ربي على صراط
مستقيم وان تولوا فقد ابلغتكم ما ارسلت به
اليكم ويستخلف ربي قوما غيركم ولا تضروني
ان ربي على كل شيء
حفيظ ولما جاء امرنا نجينا هودا والذين
امنوا معه ولما جاء امرنا نجينا هودا
والذين امنوا معه برحمه منا
ونجيناهم من عذاب
غليظ وتلك عاد جحدوا بايات ربهم وعص
رسله واتبعوا امر كل جبار
عنيد واتبعوا في هذه الدنيا لعنه ويوم
القيامه الا ان عادا كفروا ربهم الا بعدا
لعاد قوم
هود والى ثمود اخاهم صالحا قال يا قوم
اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره هو انشاكم
من الارض واستعمركم فيها فاستغفروه ثم
توبوا اليه ان ربي قريب
مجيب قالوا يا صالح قد كنت فينا مرجوا قبل
هذا اتنه اناا ان نعبد ما يعبد
اباؤنا واننا لفي شك مما تدعون اليه
مريب قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على بينه
من ربي واتاني منه رحمه واتاني منه
رحمه فمن ينصرني من الله ان عصيته فما
تزيدونني غير
تخسير ويا قوم هذه ناقه الله لكم ايه
فذروها تاكل في ارض الله ولا تمسوها
بسوء
فياخذ فياخذ عذاب
قريب فعقروها فقال تمتعوا في داركم ثلاثه
ايام ذلك وعد غير
مكذوب فلما جاء امرنا نجينا صالحا والذي
الين امنوا معه برحمه منا ومن خزي
يومئذ ان ربك هو القوي
العزيز واخذ الذين ظلموا الصيحه فاصبحوا
في ديارهم
جاثمين كان لم يغنوا فيها الا ان ثمود
كفروا ربهم الا بعدا
لثمود الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد جاءت رسلنا ابراهيم بالبشرى
قالوا سلاما قال سلام فما لبث ان جاء بعجل
حنيذ فلما راى ايديهم لا تصل اليه نكرهم
واوجسبورج
باسحاق ومن وراء اسحاق
يعقوب قالت يا ويلتا االد وانا عجوز وهذا
بعلي شيخا ان هذا لشيء
عجيب قالوا اتعجبين من امر الله رحمه الله
وبركاته عليكم اهل البيت انه حميد
مجيد فلما ذهب عن ابراهيم الروع
وجاءته البشرى يجادلنا في قوم
لوط ان ابراهيم لحليم اواهم
منيب يا ابراهيم اعرض عن هذا انه قد جاء
امر ربك وانهم اتيهم عذاب غير مردود
ولما جاءت رسلنا لوطا سيء بهم وضاق بهم
ذرعا وقال هذا يوم
عصيب
وجاءه قومه يهرعون اليه ومن قبل كانوا
يعملون
السيئات قال يا قوم
هؤلاء بناتي هن اطهر لكم فاتقوا الله ولا
خزون في ضيفي اليس منكم رجل
رشيد قالوا لقد علمت ما لنا في بناتك من
حق وانك لتعلم ما
نريد قال لو ان لي بكم قوه او اوي الى ركن
شديد قالوا يا لوط انا رسل ربك لن يصلوا
اليك
فاسر باهلك بقطع من الليل ولا يلتفت منكم
احد الا
امراتك انه مصيبها انها مصي انه مصيبها ما
اصابهم ان موعدهم الصبح اليس الصبح
بقريب فلما
جاء امرنا جعلنا عاليها
فلها وامطرنا عليها حجاره من سجيل
منضود مسومه عند ربك وما هي من الظالمين
ببعيد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبرك
وكات ان شاء
الله ان شاء
الله الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين
زاكا s
صلاه الله سبحانه
وتالى قران الله سبحانه وتالى واقيموا
الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه
زاكا الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى to our our hearts from
stinginess a purification for our money
from whatever comes to it that shouldn't
been in
it and
also a blessing in
our الله سبحانه وتالى ران
صلى الله عليه
وسلم حديث
عبدنر اللهن عمر الله سبحانه
وتى بني الاسلام على خمس
اسلام
زكاه رسول الله صلى الله عل وس مذن
جبل الله سبحانه
وتالى among
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى
قران الله سبحانه
reg الله سبحانه
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى قران والذين
يكنزون الذهب والفضه ولا ينفقونها في سبيل
الله فبشرهم بعذاب اليم يوم يحمى عليها في
نار جهنم فتكوى بها جباههم وجنوبهم
وظهورهم هذا ما كنزتم لانفسكم فذ
الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله
[Silence]
حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ‏c eight
cator
of basically are eight
categories
male who owns a
surplus and this surplus is extra to his
basic
needs and me by basic needs is basically
[Silence]
2.
نصص
[Silence]
position
2.5%
another
نصص 595
[Silence]
2. spe
الله سبحانه وتعالى سوره التوب الله
سبحانه وتعالى انما الصدقات
للفقراء والمساكين
والمساكين والعاملين عليها والمؤلفه
قلوبهم وفي الرقاب والغارمين وفي سبيل
الله وابن السبيل فريضه من
الله الله سبحانه وتعالى سكاه
[Silence]
الله
الله سبحانه
وتعالى مساكين يعملون في البحر واما
السفينه فكانت لمساكين
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
طبعا
عن الله سبحانه وتال
‏are to
fre sl
days
can
of
fuse of not
شاء
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم ان الصدقه لا تحل لغني
ولا لذي مره سوي صدقه زكاه
[Silence]
زين عبد الله
مسعود عبد الله
مسعود ‏to spend on her
father okay the other one of the
fourth category is the household of صل
عليه وسلم رسول الله صل الله عليه وسلم
الحسين رضي الله عنه was child and he ate
one of the dates of the charity he said
it out don't you know that we are forbid
froma and of رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم بنهاشم
بن عبد الملب بن علي بن
عقيل
بنال and those are forbid to take from
the the last one are
disbelievers non muslims are not given
are not allow to re can we them for
feeding not all
الحد الله سبحانه وتعالى اقول قولي هذا
واستغفر الله لي ولكم وجزاكم الله
خيرا استقم اعتدل
سو الصف سد
الخلل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والى مدين اخاهم
شعيبا قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من
اله غيره ولا تنقصوا المكيال
والميزان اني اراكم بخير واني اخاف عليكم
عذابا واني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم
محيط ويا قوم اوفوا المكيال والميزان
بالقسط ولا تبخ خسوا الناس
اشياءهم ولا تعثوا في الارض
مفسدين بقيه الله خير لكم ان كنتم
مؤمنين وما انا
عليكم
بحفيظ قالوا يا شعيب اصلاتك تامرك ان نترك
ما يعبد اباء
او ان نفعل في اموالنا ما
نشاء
انك
لانت الحليم
الرشيد قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على
بينه قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على بينه
ربي ورزقني منه رزقا
حسنا وما اريد ان اخالفكم الى ما انهاكم
عنه ان اريد الا الاصلاح ما استطعت وما
توفيقي الا
بالله عليه توكلت واليه
انيب ويا قوم لا
يجرمنكم
شقاقي ان
يصيبكم ان
يصيبكم مثل ما
اصاب ان
يصيبكم مثل ما اصاب قوم نوح او قوم هود او
قوم صالح واو قوم صالح وما قوم لوط منكم ب
عيد
واستغفروا ربكم ثم توبوا
اليه ان ربي رحيم
ودود قالوا يا شعيب ما نفقه كثيرا مما
تقول
وانا لنراك فينا
ضعيفا ولولا رهطك لرجمناك وما انت علينا
بعزيز قال يا قوم ارهطي اعز عليكم من الله
واتخذتموه
وراءكم
ظهريا ان ربي بما تعملون
عليم ويا قوم اعملوا على مكانتكم اني عامل
سوف تعلمون من ياتيه عذاب يخزيه ويحل عليه
عذاب
اليم ولما جاء امرنا نجينا شعيبا والذين
امنوا معه واخذت الذين ظلموا الصيحه
فاصبحوا في ديارهم
جاثمين كان لم يغنوا
فيها الا بعدا لمدين كما بعدت
ثمود ولقد ارسلنا موسى
باياتنا ولقد ارسلنا موسى
باياتنا الى فرعون بسلطان مبين
ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا الى فرعون
وملاه ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا
وسلطان
مبين الى فرعون وملاه فاتبعوا امر
فرعون وما امر فرعون
برشيد يقدم قومه يوم القيامه فاوردهم
النار وبئس الورد
المورود واتبعوا في هذه لعنه ويوم
القيامه بئس الرفد
المرفود ذلك من
انباء القر نقصه
عليك منها
ئم
وحصيد وما ظلمناهم ولكن ظلموا
انفسهم فما اغنت عنهم الهتهم التي يدعون
من دون الله من شيء
لما لما جاء امر ربك وما زادوهم غير و
تتبيب وكذلك اخذ ربك اذا اخذ القرى وهي
ظالمه ان اخذه اليم
شديد ان في ذلك لايه لمن خاف عذاب
الاخره ذلك يوم موعود له الناس وذلك يوم
مشهود ذلك يوم مجموع له الناس وذلك يوم
مشهود وما
نؤخره الا
لاجر
معدود يوم ياتي لا تكلم نفس الا
باذنه فمنهم شقي
وسعيد فاما الذين شقوا ففي
النار فاما الذين شقوا ففي النار لهم
فيها لهم فيها زفير
وشهيق خالدين فيها ما دامت السماوات
والارض الا ما شاء رب
ان ربك فعال لما
يريد واما الذين سعدوا ففي الجنه خالدين
فيها خالدين فيها ما دامت
السماوات والارض الا ما شاء
ربك
عطاء ير
مجذوذ الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فلا تك في مريه
مما يعبد
هؤلاء ما يعبدون الا كما يعبد
اباؤهم من قبل وانا لموفوهم
نصيبهم غير
منقوص ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب فاختلف فيه
ولولا
كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي بينهم
انهم لفي شك منه
مريب وان كلا لما
ليوفينهم ربك
اعمالهم انه بما يعملون
خبير فاستقم كما امرت ومن تاب معك ولا
تطغوا انه بما تعملون
بصير ولا تركنوا الى الذين ظلموا فتمسكم
النار وما لكم من دون الله من
اولياء ثم لا
تنصرون واقم الصلاه طرفي النهار وزلفا من
الليل ان الحسنات يذهبن السي
ذلك ذكرى
للذاكرين واصبر فان
الله واصبر فان الله لا يضيع اجر
المحسنين فلولا كان من القرون من قبلكم
اولو بقيه ينهون عن الفساد في الارض الا
الا قليلا من من انجينا منهم واتبع الذين
ظلموا ما اترفوا فيه وكانوا
مجرمين ولو شاء ربك لجعل الناس
امه
واحده وما كان ربك ليهلك القرى بظلم بظلم
واهلها
مصلحون ولو لو شاء ربك لجعل الناس
امه واحده ولا يزالون
مختلفين الا من رحم ربك ولذلك
خلقهم وتمت كلمه ربك
لاملان جهنم من الجنه والناس
اجمعين وكلا نقص عليك من
انباء الرسل ما نثبت به
فؤادك
وجاءك في هذه الحق
وموعظه وذكرى
للمؤمنين وقل للذين لا يؤمنون اعملوا على
مكانتكم انا
عاملون
وانتظروا انا منت
ولله غيب السماوات
والارض ولله غيب السماوات والارض فاعبده
وتوكل
عليه واليه يرجع
الامر كله فاعبده وتوكل
عليه وما ربك بغافل
عما تعملون
الم ر تلك ايات الكتاب المبين انا انزلناه
قرانا عربيا لعلكم
تعقلون نحن نقص عليك احسن القصص بما
اوحينا اليك هذا القران وان كنت من قبل
قله لمن
الغافلين اذ قال يوسف لابيه يا ابت اني
رايت احد عشر كوكبا والشمس والقمر والشمس
والقمر رايتهم لي
ساجدين قال يا بني لا تقصص رؤياك على
اخوتك فيكيدوا لك كيدا ان الشيطان ل
الانسان عدو
مبين وكذلك يجتبيك ربك ويعلمك من تاويل
الاحاديث ويتم نعمته عليك وعلى ال
يعقوب كما
اتها على ابويك من قبل ابراهيم
واسحاق ان ان ربك حكيم
عليم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم
واعتد الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغ ضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وكذلك يجتبيك ربك ويتم ويعلمك من
تاويل
الاحاديث ويتم نعمته عليك وعلى ال يعقوب
كما
اتمها على ابويك من قبل ابراهيم واسحاق
ان ربك عليم
حكيم ان ربك حكيم
عليم ان ربك عليم حكيم لقد كان في يوسف
واخوته ايات
للسائلين اذ قالوا ليوسف واخوه احب الى
ابينا منا ونحن
صبه ان ابانا لفي ضلال مبين اقتلوا يوسف
او اطرحوه ارضا يخل لكم وجه ابيكم وتكونوا
من بعده قوما
صالحين قال
قائل منهم لا تقتلوا
يوسف لا تقتلوا يوسف والقوه في غيابه الجب
يلتقطه بعض
السياره يلتقطه بعض السياره ان كنتم
فاعلين قالوا يا ابانا ماالك لا تامنا على
يوسف وانا له
لناصحون ارسله معنا غدا يرتع ويلعب وانا
له
لحافظون قال اني ليحزنني ان تذهبوا به
واخاف واخاف ان ياكله الذئب وانتم عنه
غافلون قالوا لئن اكله الذئب ونحن عصبه
انا اذا
لخاسرون فلما ذهبوا
واجمعوا ان يجعلوه في غيابه الجب واوحينا
اليه لتنبئنهم
بامرهم هذا وهم لا
يشعرون
وجاءوا اباهم
عشاء
يبكون قالوا يا ابانا انا ذهبنا نستبق وتر
ركنا يوسف عند
متاعنا فاكله الذئب وما انت بمؤمن لنا ولو
كنا
صادقين
وجاؤوا على قميصه بدم كذب قال بل سولت لكم
انفسكم امرا
فصبر جميل والله الله المستعان على ما
تصفون
وجاءت
سياره فارسلوا واردهم فادلى دلوه قال يا
بشرى هذا
غلام واسروه
بضاعه والله عليم بما
يعملون وشروه بثمن بخس در هم
معدوده معدوده وكانوا فيه من
الزاهدين وشروه بثمن بخس دراهم معدوده
وكانوا فيه من
الزاهدين وقال الذي اشتراه من مصر لامراته
اكرمي مثواه اكرمي مثواه عسى اي ينفعنا او
نتخذه ولدا وكذلك مكنا ليوسف في الارض
ولنعلمه من تاويل
الاحاديث والله غالب على امره
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون
ولما بلغ اشده اتيناه
حكما ولما بلغ اشده اتيناه حكما
وعلما وكذلك نجزي المحسنين وراودته التي
هو في بيتها عن نفسه
وغلقت
الابواب وغلقت الابواب وقالت هيت لك قال
معاذ الله ان انه ربي احسن
مثواي انه لا يفلح
الظالمون ولقد همت به وهم بها لولا ان راى
برهان ربه كذلك لنصرف عنه السوء والفحشاء
انه من عبادنا
المخلصين سبق الباب وقدت قميصه من دبر
والف يا سيدها لدى
الباب قالت ما
جزاء من اراد باهلك سوءا الا الا ان يسجن
او عذاب اليم قال هي راودتني عن نفسي وشهد
شاهد من اهلها ان كان قميصه قد من قبل
فصدقت فصدقت وهو من
الكاذبين وان كان قميصه قد من دبر
فكذبت فكذبت وهو من
الصادقين فلما راى قميصه قد من دبر قال
قال هذا فلما راى قميصه قد من دبر قال هذا
من
كيدكن انه من
كيدكن ان
كيدكن
عظيم يوسف اعرض عن هذا واستغفري
لذنبك واستغفري لذنبك انك
كنت من
الخاطئين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقال نسوه في المدينه امراه العزيز
تراود اتاها عن نفسه قد شغفها حبا انا
لنراها في ضلال
مبين فلما سمعت
بمكرهن ارسلت اليهن واعتدت لهن
متكا واتت كل واحده
منهن سكينا وقالت وقالت اخرج عليه
فلما راينه اكبرنه وقطعن
ايديهن وقلن حاش لله وقلن حاش لله ما هذا
بشرا ان هذا الا ملك كريم قالت
فذلكن الذي
لمتنني فيه ولقد راودته عن نفسه
فاستعصم ولئن لم يفعل ما امره
ليسجنن
وليكون من
الصاغرين قال ربي السجن احب الي مما
يدعونني اليه والا تصرف عني
كيدهن اصب اليهن واكن من الجاهلين
فاستجاب له ربه فصرف عنه
كيدهن انه هو السميع
العليم ثم بدى لهم من بعد ثم بدى لهم من
بعد ما راوا
الايات
ليسجننه حتتى حين ودخل معه السجن فتيان
قال
احدهما قال احدهما اني اراني اعصر خمرا
وقال الاخر اني اراني احمل فوق راسي خبزا
تاكل الطير منه نبئنا
بتاويله انا نراك من
المحسنين قال لا ياتيكما طعام ترزقانه الا
نباتك
بتاويله الا نباتاتك بتاويله قبل ان
ياتيكما ذلكما مما علمني ربي اني تركت مله
قوم لا يؤمنون بالله
وبالاخره هم
كافرون واتبعت مله
ابائي ابراهيم
واسحاق
ويعقوب ما كان لنا ان نشرك بالله من شيء
ذلك من فضل الله علينا وعلى الناس
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يشكرون يا صاحبي السجن اارباب
متفرقون خير الله الواحد
القهار ما تعبدون من دونه الا
اسماء
سميتموها
سميتموها انتم
واباؤكم ما انزل الله بها من سلطان ان
الحكم الا لله امر الا تع ع بدوا الا اياه
ذلك الدين القيم ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون يا صاحبي السجن اما احدكما فيسقي
ربه خمرا واما الاخر فيصلب فتاكل الطير من
راسه قضي الامر الذي فيه
تستفتيان و قال للذي ظن انه ناج منهم
اذكرني عند ربك
فانساه الشيطان ذكر ربه فلبث في السجن بضع
سنين وقال الملك اني ارى سبع بقرات سمان
ياكلهن سبع
عجاف وسبع
سنبلات خضر واخر
يابسات يا ايها الملا افتوني في رؤياي ان
كنتم للرؤيا
تعبرون قالوا اضغاث
احلام وما نحن بتاويل الاحلام
بعالمين وقال الذي نجا منهما واذكر بعد
امه انا انبئ
بتاويله انا
انبئكم
بتاويله
فارسلوا يوسف ايها الصديق افتنا في سبع
بقرات سمان ياكلهن سبع
عجاف وسبع
سنبلات خضر واخر
يابسات لعلي ارجع الى الناس لعلهم
يعلمون قال تزرعون سبع سنين دابا فما
حصدتم فذروه في
سنبله الا
قليلا الا قليلا مما
تاكلون ثم ياتي من بعد ذلك سبع عجاف ياكلن
ما قدمتم لهن
ثم ياتي من بعد ذلك سبع شداد ياكلن ما
قدمتم لهن الا
قليلا الا قليلا مما
تحصنون ثم ياتي من بعد ذلك عام فيه يغاث
الناس وفيه يعصرون
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل
السو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الد
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما
عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد لكم دينكم
ولي
دين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكب
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم
عليكم ورحمه
الله الل
[Silence]
‏h